uh why is it that when I jump off the  top of a moving train I end up in a  different spot  but when I jump up inside the moving  train I end up in a same spot  uh is this what you actually do  are you a stunt person for movies uh so  so here's the thing if the train is  going by and you jump off of it you are  still moving forward  along with the train until you hit the  ground then the train leaves you behind  and you tumble so you are moving with  the train while you are airborne okay  well watch for that the next time you do  this and of course in the train you jump  up you come down the whole train carried  you and your jump and everything with it  so you land in the same spot on the  train  but from this ground you took an ark  you hopped